well we're looking at chocolate datasets
today so I thought I'd bring some
research I'm yeah good and definitely
relevant we've been looking at
techniques like data visualization to
try and explore our data and start to
draw some initial you know conclusions
or hypotheses we're going to start to
move towards kind of modeling our data
and actually trying to extract proper
knowledge from this data because
remember just because we've got data
doesn't mean we've got knowledge now
this is going to be a kind of iterative
process we're going to need to clean up
our data to make it as useful as
possible we need to transform it so that
we can combine datasets together and
statistically measure our datasets and
then we're going to need to reduce it
sometimes if our data set is too big and
unmanageable and this combination of
cleaning data and transforming data and
reducing data is a kind of cycle where
we're going to iterate this until our
data set it's a smallest most useful
form it can be so if we've got redundant
variables which are basically the same
as others or we've got duplicates these
are all problems that we need to sort
out because if we're going to be
analyzing data with these kinds of
issues we're just making our life
slightly more difficult it's
computationally inefficient and you know
in the worst case we could draw the
wrong conclusions you might be surprised
and disappointed when you get your first
data set that actually it's not quite as
nice as you were hoping and it's gonna
need some cleaning up maybe there's
missing values maybe there's outliers
that need to be dealt with because this
yeah they're warping your distributions
and your and your medians and means
right and perhaps you also got noise in
your data set right these few things we
can start to address with cleaning so
cleaning data is essentially the idea of
trying to correct or fill in any missing
values or remove those bits completely
you might be surprised but there's
missing data at all
I mean Oh what are we not paying
attention like we've got one job and
that was to collect the data and we seem
to have got missing data but actually
it's quite common because I mean for
example if you're if you're trying to
track patient records over time maybe we
didn't show up to an appointment or
maybe you in a hospital when they
weren't there when they needed to have
their temperature taken right and then
your trend line of your temperature over
time is going to be missing some values
maybe you've got data going back for
hundreds of years and they didn't have
certain techniques and certain
measurement systems back then so they
only have other kinds of data so missing
data is
we common rye and we're gonna have to be
able to deal with it so the data set
we're looking at today is a kind of
ratings for chocolate bars this is why
ate my chocolate or at least that's why
I'm telling myself so we'll read the
data in we've got ten different
variables we've got about 1,700 nearly
observations and let's have a quick look
using the summary so we've got things
like the company would produce for
chocolate the name of the chocolate
reviews the cocoa percentage the type of
being this kind of information right and
you can imagine what you might do if you
were trying to produce better chocolate
it's a look at a huge amount of this
kind of data and work out what it is
that customers like and what it is they
don't like but this is going to be quite
common in market research so the first
thing we're going to do right we've
we've received this data we know now
what the columns are but we don't really
know anything else other than this so
we're going to have to start looking
through and seeing first of all is there
any missing data so we're going to use
the S supply function for this the s
supply function will apply a function
over our data set so for each column or
each attribute of our data we're going
to apply this and the function we're
going to use we're lighting ourselves so
it's going to be the sum for any time
where our item is either blank or na now
blank means an empty string and na means
literally not applicable right which is
something that comes up in data from
time to time alright so in any case both
of these are missing values and so we're
going to treat them both the same so if
we apply this to our chocolate data set
then we're going to see that for example
there are eight missing names there are
seven missing review dates and there are
four missing Coco percentages so for
each row in our data there are four rows
where the Coco percent is missing right
now that's not too bad for I mean this
is as data set of nearly 1,700 items for
it's not too bad that's quite quite
expected you might imagine that if
you're pooling this data from lots of
different sources people are going to
forget to add datum in or they weren't
able to record data on that day there's
a huge amount of reasons why you might
have missing data and now it starts to
become a little bit of a problem when we
look at things like bean type because
bean type has got 1200 missing values
that's a huge proportion of a data set
and in that case we might have to do
something about this so the only issue
we've got is that 1200 is not relish
it's just an amount of rows it's not
relative to the
of a data set so we're going to use the
exact same function any empty rows but
this time we're going to divide by the
total number of rows so we can get a
percentage for how much of a missing
data we've got so we can see for example
but company name has zero missing data
whereas beam type has 74 percent missing
data so that's a huge problem now
a kind of general rule of thumb is if
you've got over half your data is
missing it's going to be quite hard to
estimate or guess what that data is
going to be that's when you might want
to start thinking about removing it so
what we want to do is we want to extract
any of the names of any of our
attributes that have this sort of over
let's say 60% missing all right so we're
going to start by calculating always
percentages and saving them in a
variable and then we're going to select
only those percentages where the value
is over point 6 right 60 percent so
we're gonna say any attribute where the
attribute is over point 6 and that is
just being typed at point 7 for right or
74% so we can now delete beam type
ourselves so we could say something like
chaco all the rows for being type is
null and by setting that to nah that's
just going to delete that column we can
also do it automatically so we could
actually pass in those attributes that
we just calculated as a parameter so
that would be this line here so be
something like chaco all rows that's
here the names of any attributes where
the percentage missing is greater than
0.6 and that's going to just delete
being type right it's not a lot we can
do about being type we've only got 25%
issue of a data it's not enough to start
guessing what beam types are going to be
in other chocolate bars let's have a
look at now our rows of data voters for
each instance they're going to have a
number of attributes
now there's 9 left and we want really to
keep the instances that have the
majority of their data right so we're
gonna apply my so this is going to be
row wise to dimension 1 so that's the
rows we're gonna count any of it a blank
or n/a for each row over our data set
and we're going to put this into missing
so what it is going to do is return a
list of values for every single row but
tells you how many missing items are
there in that rug so we can now look at
the first few missing items so we're
going to order them right by larges
first and then we're going to show just
the first few and you can see but
actually some of them are missing seven
and six attributes
that's quite a serious situation because
it was only nine lights only only got a
couple of entries in their fields now
let's do this again as a percentage of
the number of attributes so this is
exactly the same thing but this time
we're dividing by the number of columns
which is nine and we're going to have a
look at the top of these and so you can
see that we're missing 77% of some of
these initial attributes that's a real
problem
missing is the same length as the number
of rows we've got so we can actually
look up any rows where there's a greater
percentage of missing values and we want
and just remove them from the data set
so what we're going to do that is a bit
like this so there's a choco is choco
anywhere we're missing is less than or
point seven and then all the columns and
what that's going to do is select only
the rows we want where they've got a
nice amount of data so machaca dataset
is going to be a little bit smaller now
but much more useful to us we don't
really want to be trying to do things
like machine learning or statistics when
70% of some of the data is missing right
that isn't going to be a good idea so
it's quite easy just to delete data
right I mean in some sense it's just
more convenient to do that in general
the rule is that if you've got more than
50 or 60% missing data it's a good idea
to delete it right delete are the
instances or the attributes depending on
how much data you've got missing and
where if you're missing a huge amount of
data then you're not going to be able to
recreate it by let's say using an
average right we've got so little later
that an average isn't going to be
reliable if we have got sufficient data
that we could maybe start to infer what
these missing values might be we can
start to try and replace them instead of
deleting them so what we might do is we
might for example set them all to zero
maybe if an attribute is missing we can
say well okay if it's missing we'll just
not use it and we'll say it's zero now
whether you do that it's going to depend
on what the attribute is something zero
is not a useful property right and we'll
look at that in the chocolate dataset in
a moment what we might also do is we
might start to add the data set mean
into those attributes so maybe we don't
know what the rating for this chocolate
bar is but we can guess but it's going
to be around the average rating for any
chocolate bar again this is going to
depend on your situation right you're
still making up datum in some sense
you've got to be very careful about what
you do here so we've deleted as much of
our chakra data as we feel comfortable
doing now let's see if we can fill in
some of
missing values with appropriate
replacements so let's have a look at our
attributes alright so we've got company
name reference things like this being
tab has been removed but we still got
things like the bean origin and the
ratings and there's a few of these
missing from our data set can we
estimate these rather than completely
removing them from the data set
obviously the less data you use for less
useful things like machine learning are
going to be so let's look at an
attribute and see what we can do so if
we look at bar price I bats the price of
each chocolate bar we can see that
there's a few missing values somewhere
around 3% that's something we want to
deal with but we've got enough data you
know 97% maybe we can start to guess
what the prices of these chocolate bars
might be now this is a good instance of
a time when you wouldn't want to just
populate with zeros right no chocolate
bar is free I wish and so what we need
to do is produce a reliable value to
represent an unknown price rather than
just setting them all to be zero so what
we could do here is something like this
we could set every missing bar price to
be the average of all the chocolate bar
prices and that way at least we're not
warping our distribution up or down
we're keeping it exactly the same we're
gonna say for the chocolate data set for
any row where bar price is n/a and for
all columns we're going to set the bar
price to be the mean of all the bar
prices and we're gonna obviously remove
any na s from that calculation of what
it's not going to work and that's
already worked so now if we recalculate
our missing values you'll see that bar
price now has zero missing values
so we've fixed that problem great so
that was quite an easy one right bar pie
seems to me to be quite an intuitive
time when you would just calculate an
average and put it in right now actually
maybe not because you know bar price
might depend on where in the world we're
selling it or you know what company is
producing the chocolate bar so could we
do the same thing for rating if we look
if we take the sum of all the NA values
in rating it's eight like so there are
eight chocolate bars for which there is
no rating so what we can do is we could
do something called a stratified
replacement we could say well let's
group our chocolate bars by country or
by company calculate those averages and
then we can specifically fill in
companies missing ratings based on what
that company actually show
in the market rather than just an
average over everything so what we're
going to do is we're going to calculate
an aggregate function over of the
ratings by company and we're going to
calculate a median median is a little
bit more robust to outliers so maybe you
make up a very very expensive or very
very cheap line the median will get what
middle value is right so this is going
to be per company and we can set the
columns to be a little bit more helpful
using coal names and so now our per
company if we look at it is each company
and the median rating of chocolate bar
form I think one to five your fingers
data set is going so now we know that
data per company we can actually fill
those in now you could automate this
process we don't have much missing data
so let's just show an example of doing
it by hand so this is the line of code
we're going to do and I'll talk through
it so we're going to say for the
chocolate data set for any value where
the chocolate rating is n/a for missing
right and the company is Vai Kuna we
want to set the rating to be equal to
the vikon entry in our new per company
average or median and that's going to
fill in that value there so we do this
for all the missing companies and what
we're going to find is that we've
replaced all our missing values with
appropriate medians for those ratings
per company so the last thing we might
find in our data is outliers so let's
imagine we do a box plot of cocoa
percentage right so I'm going to produce
a box plot of a cocoa percentage now
maybe our assumption is that cocoa
percentage in some way informs what the
rating is going to be because maybe a
higher cocoa percentage tastes nicer
I don't really know about chocolate so
if we look at this box plot what we'll
see is we've got actually quite a tight
distribution of cocoa percentage right
between about 50% and just above 80% but
you can see there are three outliers
when it produces a box plot or I will
show outliers is anything that is more
than three standard deviations away from
the median what we do with these
outliers is going to be a judgment call
it's going to depend on a situation so
for example we have an outlier here
which is above a hundred percent now
that makes no sense we can't have a
chocolate bar with more than a hundred
percent cocoa right doesn't make sense
so that is obviously a mistake we would
delete that item right and probably
delete the whole row or we estimate that
value
based on a stratified average or a
different average for these lower ones
this is a judgment call one is just
above 20 and one is up closer to 30% I
don't know whether those of outliers or
not right is it possible to make a
viable chocolate bar with 20% cocoa I
mean it may be right you're going to
have to know a little bit something
about your the situation but your data
was collected in and whether that's
reasonable so you might for example
delete the bottom one as a mistake but
keep the top one because that's just a
low amount of cocoa so this is what
cleaning data is about we're going to
have missing data we're going to have
outliers we might have noise and you're
going to have to look for your data and
try and condense it and remove all these
problems we do this so that we can more
effectively transform our data later and
also reduce our data if we need to and
then eventually your datasets going to
be really nice so that we can do things
like modeling or machine learning on it
my fuel economy is messaging miles per
gallon but of course I don't pump fuel
in my in gallons I pump it in liters and
then but when I run anywhere so short
distances I run in kilometers and I run
in kilometers per hour so I'm using two
different systems there